I think that what this video really is
is just a tour of the valley was it
wrong that he get creeped out by that
carwash sign all cloth and then in
quotes that says soft touch look hands
off me alright I'm showing this is the
part of LA you're never gonna see this
is up north in the valley Oh another
apartment building yeah cuz we need more
people I'd love to be an old guy living
in the valley someday you know just
walking around my striped shirt just
talk to the other old biddies down there
at the coffee shop
drinking again and thinking of when when
you loved me I'm having a few I wanted a
drink Roscoe Boulevard okay this [ __ ]
lunatic looking down at a goddamn phone
I wish it was a [ __ ] sign of some
[ __ ] you know I don't mind her cuz she's
kind of aggressive they come up and they
go to like bump into you this guy looked
at NS like he's gonna get discovered I
swear to god there's something about the
valley that just makes you like 2:00
3:00 in the afternoon you just want to
go into into a bar you know meet some
guy that did a guest star like emergency
I used to be on a show watch yeah I was
on chips get the [ __ ] out of here
what was that Rick Estrada like eyes a
great guy see that guy right over there
he should have made that [ __ ] left
and he didn't make it
then he turns his directional and that's
a big la thing you'll wait till the
light turns green and then you put your
directional on you leave that person
right up against your bumper this guy
sells sandwiches and doughnuts just got
a picture you got a pic of [ __ ]
it's probably delicious right look at
that piece of [ __ ]
she sees rundown strip malls and it'll
be like the greatest [ __ ] donut you
have ahead
that was a nice u-turn that guy just
made there I like that one you know he
did it he got out of the way everything
was fine guys having a [ __ ] cookout
right here dude that is like next-level
homeless who the valley is the place to
be homeless he's cleaning up after
himself oh [ __ ] the adultcon why are we
driving in the opposite direction of
that dude everybody watches porn but can
you imagine how he's showing up to that
[ __ ] thing really big fan of your
work is creeping him out oh my god could
you have enough security at that thing
oh [ __ ] see know what I did there I just
stopped so this guy could cut the corner
you gotta look out for the trucks that's
another thing you got to watch out for
there's all these [ __ ] who cut in
front of trucks when they you know they
got all that weight behind them they
can't stop
what I love about the valley look at all
those signs out there all these old
school signs back when we thought we
were gonna like colonize the moon and
[ __ ] you know us Fitness baga Center
old school movie theater
dude this is the [ __ ] I bet there's some
really good places to eat out here and
it [ __ ] in-and-out burger without a
line Wow
oh there's the line ain't that this so
no traffic I'm doing a bunch of [ __ ] you
shouldn't be doing I'm looking at the
drive-through it [ __ ] in and out
how does Burger King survive this close
to an in and out there's nobody in there
there's a whole bunch of nothing right
[ __ ] there that when you get a kid
people buy it buy a big [ __ ] pink
teddy bear jay-z's you see that lady
with a terry bradshaw shirt with the
fishnets maybe she's some of the talent
there at the Spearmint Rhino Jesus have
you ever seen so many Sun damaged people
in your life you get [ __ ] get out
here man this is the desert if I lived
here I would sweep up all of that
[ __ ] trash just for my own [ __ ]
well-being look at that was at the
original Walmart where the [ __ ] are we
do the valleys this [ __ ] it's a place to
be what a house cost out
[Applause]